but first the Prime Minister is visiting
Brussels tomorrow to try and hold talks
with the President of the European
Commission jean-claude Juncker and ahead
of the trip we're joined from
Cambridgeshire by the appropriate
Secretariat Stephen Buckley thank you
very much for being with us this morning
good morning I'm looking forward to
hopefully getting some guidance on
whether or not we're any closer to a
brexit deal but before that I just want
to start with some of the revelations
we've seen from David Cameron's book and
specifically the charge that he's laid
at Boris Johnson which is that his
concerns about sovereignty were
secondary to another concern for Boris
what was the best outcome for him the
conclusion I'm left with is he risked an
outcome he didn't believe in because it
would help his political career does
Boris Johnson really believe in brexit
it is he led the campaign and you recall
Sophie at the time the remain side was
expected to win so the more prudent
thing if it someone was looking purely
at their career would have been to back
remain as I remember myself because I
bet leave as the only remember the
Whip's office to do so and remain would
have been the easier career choice oh
boy Johnson led the campaign he did so
because he believes in grexit and he's
committed to delivering it and I think
the main thing really with the David
Cameron books will be to look at the job
that he and David he and George Osborne
did in terms of repairing the economy I
think that was the key achievement are
of those years but in terms of the
brexit the Prime Minister was committed
to leave you talking there about how
David Cameron will be remembered and do
you think people will look back on his
time in office fondly I do I think
you've got to remember the situation we
found in 2010 the government was
borrowing one pound in every four under
labor they had crushed the economy of
course it's nothing compared to what
Jeremy Corbyn would do if he was put in
charge of the economy now but we
inherited an economy in appalling shape
and what David Cameron did was repair
that economy and actually paved the way
for the very positive spending review
that the current Chancellor such a Javed
was able to do which has and that
enabled us to put the extra 20,000
police on the street to put a record
investment 34
billion into our NHS to give teachers
the biggest increase in their starting
salary an increase of six thousand
pounds and David Cameron and George
Osborne really paved the way for that by
taking many other tough decisions in
2010 you say they paved the way for it
it sounds a bit like you're just ripping
up any fiscal responsibility that the
Conservative Party was once known for no
we took the tough decisions we were
borrowing one pound in for under labor
everyone will remember the 2008 crash
the damage that was caused - yeah but it
was exaggerated by the the excessive
spending in the run-up to it and the
fact that we were borrowing beyond our
means so so David Cameron George Osborne
deserve credit for the measures they
took but it's right having taken those
decisions we're now in a position to
invest in our public services and to
level up and you saw that with the prime
minister's announcements in terms of
transport schemes in the north of
England we're keen to level up in all
parts of the United Kingdom and actually
as a result of the stewardship of the
economy we're now in a position to get
that extra spending for example the
extra 20,000 police officers which my
constituents and many others want to say
okay well let's talk about brexit shall
we yeah Boris Johnson's given an
interview in today's mail on Sunday
where he portrays at the UK is like the
Incredible Hulk
the madder Hulk gets the stronger Hulk
get effectively saying that if there is
a breakdown in the negotiation if you
can't a deal he's just gonna leave at
the end of October anyway so does Boris
Johnson just think that rules are
something but other people to follow as
pond of course has passed a law saying
he needs to ask for an extension in that
case well the Hulk was a winner as you
know Sophie and was very extremely
popular and and while they were backing
a character and a leader who's the Hulk
then one who's on the chicken burners
Jamie Corbin is I mean the fact is that
the Prime Minister is committed to
delivering bricks it is what people
voted for were now three years on from
that referendum and my constituents here
in Cambridgeshire like many across the
country want to see Briggs it done they
want to see is get it done and actually
move on to the domestic agenda through
the Queen's speech so isn't
oughtn't we get brick sit over the line
it's best to do it with a deal but it's
important whether it's with a deal or
without a deal we actually get this done
well let's talk about the chances of
getting a deal shall we because this
really is the important issue of today
you know putting aside their kind of
destructions of the Incredible Hulk is
progress really been made on getting a
deal it is I mean there's been detailed
technical talks led by David Frost the
Prime Minister's your provider that be
meeting Misha Barney a steam the Prime
Minister will be seeing President
Juncker
tomorrow I'll be meeting with Michel
Barnier tomorrow so there's extensive
talks been happening both at a technical
level but also at a political level the
Prime Minister was with the tea shock on
Monday I was in Poland on Thursday
Friday so there's been a huge amount of
work going on behind the scenes we can
see a landing zone in terms of a future
deal but there is significant work still
to do so the talks tomorrow will be an
important step forward as part of that
and they build on significant discussion
that's been happening at a technical
level what is the landing zone then
let's get specific what is the landing
zone that you see well I think there's
two aspects to that landing zone firstly
in terms of the withdrawal agreement
it's the fact that the backstop needs to
go we've been very clear with the EU
about that Parliament has rejected it
two three times it would involve people
in Northern Ireland taking laws over
which they'd have no vote and therefore
the backstop has to go from that we draw
an agreement and indeed EU leaders
themselves have said that they have open
to being creative and flexible in terms
of future arrangements then in terms of
the political declaration we've
addressed one of the key questions from
the EU which is what sort of future
relationship is the UK seeking we're
very clear we want a best-in-class
free-trade agreement
certain issues then flow in terms of
changes to the political declaration as
a result of that so we've been having
those technical discussions discussing
also with Northern Ireland leaders which
the sacred state for Northern Ireland
and others have been doing so a Shuja
map has been happening behind the scenes
we're very clear what it is we need in
order to get a deal through Parliament
and those are the discussions that we've
been having
I just want to pick up on something that
you just said in that answer about
Northern Ireland who the backstop of
course is at the center of all this you
were saying that the back stops
unacceptable because it would mean
Northern Ireland accepting laws on which
they have nuovo is that the issue here
if Northern Ireland had a say or concent
it if you like to some of the changes
could you see a backstop where there
were some divergence between Northern
Ireland and the rest of the UK well I
think it's also part of that consent is
important of course Sophie but part of
that is also the interplay with the
Belfast Good Friday Agreement we as a
government are absolutely committed to
the Belfast Good Friday Agreement
sometimes that's presented by the U as
simply an Irish issue it's a shared
issue but the Irish government of the UK
government are absolutely committed to
the Belfast Good Friday Agreement and
you will know that a key part of that
was the need for consent from both
communities within Northern Ireland and
sometimes it's said that it's simply the
dup that ever concerned with the
backstop that's not correct
there's other leading a much respected
figures people like the Nobel Prize
winner Lord Trimble who have expressed
concern lorb you one of the key
architects of the Belfast agreement have
expressed concern with the backstop so
it is important we move forward
with the consent of both sides of the
community in Northern Ireland and that
is a key aspect of the Belfast Good
Friday Agreement itself so that's very
much part of the thinking and part of
the consultations that we're having so
and I know it sounds quite technical but
I kind of feel that this is really the
important part to get to the grips with
where we are in the talks are you saying
that there aren't red lines on
divergence between Northern Ireland and
the rest of the UK if there is the
crucial consent element then what the
Prime Minister be absolutely clear on
and you will have heard him say it many
times is the UK will leave as a whole we
will ensure that the sovereignty of the
UK is protected but it's also important
that we reflect the Belfast Good Friday
Agreement one of the key concerns with
the backstop is the fact that it is not
consistent in the view of many within at
Northern Ireland with the Belfast Good
Friday Agreement so that's
out of the discussions now in a very
detailed level of course there are
already areas such as on animal and
plant health where there is an all
island approach so there are issues
within island already that are part of
the agreement already within the way the
role of Island economy operates we can
get into those details as part of the
talks but that is different from the
principle of the backstop and the
backstop needs to go if you manage to
bring back a deal will any conservative
MP who votes against it hath withdrawn
well I mean issues a whipping are for
the chief whip you know I've got enough
to focus on in terms of negotiations and
and that is what I will focus on so I
leave looking for the chief wit but I
think if they were if it was I think the
key issue is is only the key issue is
when I listen to business leaders when I
listen to constituents what a clear
message I get is people want this done
they want bricks it done they want to
get on to the agenda the 20,000 extra
for the police the record investment in
the NHS they increase in starting
salaries for teachers that's what they
want this government to get on and they
want breaks it down and I think many
conservative MPs share that desire they
want to see brexit delivered they
recognize that that's best done with a
deal a deal that delivers the
implementation period that gives
business the confidence to invest were
already at a stage where we have record
in with investment the highest level of
inward investment within Europe the
third highest in the the world so the
economy is strong employment is high
unemployment's at a record low and a
deal will allow businesses then to kick
on and to have further investments so I
think conservative MPs and indeed and
peas across the Commons say they want a
deal we think we can get a deal but it
has to be one that addresses the central
concern and that is the backstop I'm
keen to talk about the implication is no
deal you were saying that the best way
to leave is with a deal and we've seen
of course operation yellowhammer
documents are published the government's
reasonable worst-case planning scenarios
for leaving the EU without an agreement
and
just to run through some of it it said
there's going to be major delays at
ports the fresh food suppliers could be
hit prices could rise medicines could be
particularly vulnerable to severe
extended delays is that a price worth
paying for leaving on the 31st of
October I don't feel anything that's
what's happened it will happen I mean
we're preparing for a worse scenario but
putting more measures to ensure that
does not happen and let me just give you
an example from Friday I was discussing
in Poland we're there haulage industry
and also with their poultry such
industry 84,000 Polish jobs in poultry
they were saying they don't wanna see
any delays if you have fresh poultry
coming across any delay to that risk
losing that there's 1,200 polish lorries
on our road so so the EU countries don't
want to see delays at Calais the Irish
government a 40% of their exports go
through David two-thirds of their own
medicines come through Great Britain
they don't want to see delays either so
there's a common interest across Europe
it's not just the UK that wants to
ensure that this is the flow of goods
through the short straights it's also EU
countries whether that's the the
truckers the the poultry businesses in
Poland or whether it's those
supermarkets in Ireland so there's a
common interest there we're taking a
huge amount of work and doing a huge
amount of work to ensure we've got the
right preparation in place Michael Gove
is leading on that within government
with daily meetings to ensure that we're
ready for that but it's prudent we
prepare and that's exactly what we're
doing you say that no one wants it but
just because nobody wants something to
happen doesn't mean that something won't
happen does it and these are the
government's own worst case - let me
finish the question and one point one
worth the warning in yellowhammer is
about medicines now a lot of our viewers
will be really really concerned that
they may not be able to get the
medicines that they need if there is a
No Deal Bret said can you guarantee that
everyone will get the medicine they need
if we leave without ideal well
irrespective of Briggs it there are any
one time the Department of Health will
tell you up to around 50 medical lines
where there are disruptions just as part
of the normal
run of business I mean you may recall
covering I'm sure on the program a
couple of weeks ago in terms of HRT so
that at any one point there is
disruption to supplies the question I
think you're saying is within brexit is
there going to be further description
and that is why we've put a framework in
place for extra capacity we've got air
freight capacity as well for anything
that's urgent the pharmaceutical
companies have been working on this for
several years in terms of additional
stock they themselves have put in place
additional flow capacity as well so
there's a huge amount of work being done
on this but again this is something that
is a shared interest it's in the --use
interest to keep the flow not just in
terms of medical goods into the UK and
on to island but also in terms of
medical goods from the UK and which many
within Europe themselves rely so it's
right we prepare for this
we're meeting daily we're engaging with
the pharmaceutical companies but we've
been working on this for two three years
we've got over 300 work streams across
vital preparing for this so a huge
amount of work has been done and this is
something that happens in any events as
part of business as usual within the
Department of Health and just finally
and we've got the Supreme Court battle
at next week on whether or not it was
lawful for the Prime Minister to suspend
Parliament what reason did the Prime
Minister give to the Queen for promoting
parlament I think you know that
conversations between a prime minister a
queen or a private matter they're not an
issue that are shared with the cabinet
of course the the court in England took
a different view to the court in
Scotland we respect the decision of the
court it's right that this matter now
goes to the UK supreme court and the
government will abide by the decision of
the UK Supreme Court I mean that is the
the normal flow of these things and
that's an absolutely proper